let's go next to our caller from the six
for six
area code who's calling today from six
for six hey David this is Chris how you
doing hey Chris how are you good so this
is in response to your hey trumpets just
tell me the truth video okay which sort
of felt like a like a call to arms
almost for Donald Trump supporters sort
of admit that he's a racist is that a
correct assumption of the thesis of the
video no I mean the the point was not so
much to get the trumpets to admit that
Trump is a racist but it's more
importantly it wasn't to every Trump
estai was not implying every Trump astiz
racist but the ones who are should just
say yeah I liked from xenophobic
rhetoric just just tell me you know
right so sort of what I'm going at is
that it's been a really common strategy
among the Democrats to label their
opposition as racist and my fear is that
this is sort of going to fall under deaf
ears
like you use the word fatigue I think
that's the perfect word to use in this
situation as well so basically my
question is can the Democrats win on a
platform of labeling their opposition as
racists or will this fall under deaf
ears for the moderate yes so the I
disagree with the premise of your
question because nobody is I've not seen
any of the candidates currently running
for the 2020 Democratic primary where I
could say their platform is to call
Trump and his supporters racist so the
this in that sense I reject the the sort
of foundation of your question and that
being said I do think that you are
correctly pointing out that merely
alleging racism is not a political
strategy and that you need to be able to
connect with voters on more than that
particularly because there are lots of
racist and xenophobic voters so this is
sort of my point you and I we may
disagree on the degree to which calling
people racist as Democratic strategy but
it sounds like you and I agree that it
is not a good political strategy to the
extent that anyone is employing it well
even like with Kamala Harris she really
heavily went after Joe Biden over the
bus issue
where it felt like that was sort of the
central point of what she was trying to
accomplish through the debate yeah it
was totally calculated and it and it
worked in terms of optics but there it
was clear that it was a complete
calculation that had been made ahead of
time all right but don't you agree that
the candidates like if you look at their
Twitter I remember yesterday Bernie
Sanders is like we must admit that we
have a xenophobic and racist president
blah blah blah this is a very common
thing we're seeing more and more of and
I'm just worried that that's going to
alienate the moderates yeah I mean
listen it's going to alienate the
racists for sure and I think you're
right that if there is a sort of
swayable middle in terms of the election
if all they feel like they're seeing
from candidates is allegations that
Trump is racist it's not going to be
particularly good but to be clear my
message on I think it was Monday maybe
it was Tuesday my message was not about
running a campaign about Trump is a
racist it's I would just respect
Trumpets who are xenophobic and racist
much more if they came clean about why
they like Trump instead of couching at
his economic or trade policy or whatever
else that's all it was it was not by any
means suggesting Democrats run a
campaign based on Trump is racist it's
also hard for people to understand that
because every single speech that Trump
does he talks about how good the economy
is doing for marginalized groups like
black people and Latino people yes so on
one-year they're hearing people saying
that their candidate is a racist but
then on their other ear they're hearing
the candidate himself talk about how
good the lives of black people and
Latino people are so it's confusing well
that's the case in politics all the time
the debt is up the debt is down the
deficit is up the deficit is down we're
winning the war in Iraq were never
should have been in Iraq I mean death
that's not particularly new the fact
that voters are hearing literally
opposite stories from different people
in politics that's a that's politics
right so what you're saying is I guess
the thesis of what I was asking was do
you think this could alienate moderates
and you're saying I'm working on a false
premise but could what a Lee well you
said do I think that Democrats running
on Trump is racist could alienate
moderates my response was
I don't really think any candidate is
running on that although candidates are
talking about Trump's xenophobia okay
great I mean I completely disagree but
thanks for having the conversation about
it all right Chris appreciate the call
thank you so much